Jean-Philippe Pierron vous êtes
philosophe spécialiste de la question du
soin et de l'éthique médicale réflexion
qui aujourd'hui englobe non seulement
les autres hommes mais également la
nature les animaux et même la montagne
puisque votre dernier livre nous enjoint
à méditer comme une montagne d'autre
part vous êtes croyant alors je dis
parce que la dimension spirituelle est
très importante dans votre écologie
alors peut-être justement on peut
commencer par une définition de ce que
vous entendez par l'
spiritualité
oui
euh je m'attendais pas en fait à une
présentation ainsi et et donc le si on
installe la question de la croyance y
compris avec les doutes qu'il a
qu'ilhite et comment dire les
incertitudes et les inquiétudes en fait
qui la structure c'est comme ça que je
me définirais je dirais plus je
définirait plus comme un cherchant qu'un
croyant
mais le en fait l'idée des C spirituel
actualité
elle est une manière de dire que quand
on parle des questions d'écologie les
enjeux sont souvent des enjeux de
science et il nous faut les
savoirs parce que une bonne une bonne
partie en fait des des enjeux deécologie
aujourd'hui échappe à nos sensibilités
tout simplement parce qu'ils sont
invisibles même s'ils sont très
consistants que ça soit les enjeux
climatiques ou l'érosion d'une
biodiversité qu'on ne connaît pas donc
il y a des enjeux de savoir il y a des
enjeux en fait d'action enfin qui
relèvent disons du champ du devoir pour
le dire ainsi que ce soit les
perspective éthique et politique donc la
question de qu'est-ce qu'on fait
personnellement ou collectivement et
donc c'est ce que fait l'écologie
politique mais à côté de l'écologie
scientifique d'un côté et de l'écologie
politique de l'autre il y a une
troisième dimension qui est la dimension
du sensible et du sensible à la fois
dans sa dimension esthétique et dans sa
réception intérieure et donc moi
j'aurais tendance à tirer la question de
l'écospiritualité de ce côté en disant
que les le la transition écologique
qu'est qu'est-ce qu'elle nous fait et
bien elle nous fait précisément et elle
nous fait intérieurement alors nous elle
le fait du point de vue de de ce qu'elle
n de ce qu'elle a comme impact sur nos
subjectivités on les connaît ses impacts
déjà du côté de la psychologie hein on
parle aujourd'hui d'écopsychologie hein
une des formes poss possible lesco
anxiété mais plus profondément elle
impacte aussi le sens même de ce que
signifie pour nous être vivant sur terre
et donc au sens très très large sans que
ça soit affilié à une tradition
religieuse la la la notion d'abord
d'écospiritualité et une catégorie donc
trans releligieux si on veut en cas non
immédiatement affilier elle est une
manière de dire que les les questions
d'écologie sont aussi des questions
d'intériorité qui interrogent bien
comment celles-ci peuvent se repenser
dans le rapport à leur dehors et à leurs
interdépendances avec tous les êtres
tous les vivants y compris des êtres non
vivants puisqueune montagne bah c'est
tout la question de qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'une montagne alors vous proposez même
une méthode l'échobiographie c'est quoi
une échobiographie en fait fait ça part
de l'idée de de quand nous répondons à
la question qui suis-je que disons-nous
et nous racontons des histoires comme
disait anarent à sa façon et donc le
donc nos identités sont pour le formuler
encore autrement narrative donc si si
dire c'est raconter que racontonsnous de
nous et que que taisons-nous et donc
l'idée desciographie c'est de dire que
la plupart de nos biographies sont
souvent des biographies à notre insu ou
délibérément officiel c'est qu'en fait
sorte de curriculum euh vité en fait qui
disent ce qui serait bon de dire parce
qu'on pense que c'est ça qui nous
définif vraiment alors qu'en fait il y a
une dimension cachée nos biographies du
moins dans nos sociétés dont
l'échobiographie à sa manière peut être
l'expression c'estd en fait le ce qui
nous constitue c'est aussi toute une
infinité de liens je dis interdépendance
en fait avec des des êtres humains bien
sûr mais ou des êtres autres qu'humains
des milieux une source Un arbre des
animaux des ambiances une qualité de l'
CLIRE une ambiance sonore et cetera en
fait qui contribue à définir qui nous
sommes hein je prends souvent moi un
exemple pour illustrer ça même dans le
langage très gris de l'administration
qui est par exemple un numéro de
sécurité sociale moi dans mon numéro de
sécurité sociale il y a un 54 qui
signifie ou qui renvoie à la meurthre et
à la moiselle en fait comme de rivières
sans lesquelles d'e certaine façon je
sauraai pas qui je suis c'est pas des
grands fleuves ils sont pas grandioses
hein c'est pas la comment dire c'est pas
la c'est pas l'Amazone ou c'est pas le
rein mais ma ma biographie se raconte à
l'égard de son milieu et et avec ce
milieu c'est que le donc l'idée
d'échobiographie c'est de dire que nous
écrivons qui nous sommes
individuellement ou collectivement parce
que l'échobiographie elle a un sens
intime mais elle peut aussi avoir une
signification politique la question
d'une communauté enfin d'une
biopolitique Dee certaine manière donc
l'écobiographie c'est dire ça c'est dire
au fond que pour honorer à sa juste
profondeur en fait les sujets que nous
sommes les les et bien
il y a peut-être un travail de
reconnaissance euh à faire à l'égard de
tous ces liens qui nous font être euh et
qui sont nos nos dépendan non
nécessairement aliéné à l'égard
effectivement du de nos milieux hein je
préfère cette notion celle
d'environnement de ce point de vue-là
parce que précisément on n'est pas
autour c'est pas autour de nous nous
sommes tressés avec eux hein c'est ça
qui est dans den cité des
descobiographie alors cette question du
lien justement elle est elle est
intéressante parce que euh parfois elle
elle pousse certains écologistes à à à
minorer ou voire à exclure la place de
l'homme alors pour vous l'écologie n'est
pas un anti-humanisme comment s'articule
justement ce jeu au nous et d'ailleurs
c'est le titre de l'un de vos ouvrages
comment on articule un jeu au nous sans
sans néanmoins renoncer au jeu oui alors
c'est une enfin c'est un enjeu je crois
qui qui qui est décisif parce qu'
effectivement à un moment donné on a pu
vouloir en fait opposer humanisme
écologie en disant de certaine manière
que il y avait là une manière de
dilution de tous les grands acquis de à
la fois des lumières des grandes pensées
d'émancipation à l'égard de ce qui nous
alienne et ce qu'on appelle entre
guillemets la nature peut aussi être
aliénante il s'agit pas de de minorer là
aussi euh que la les les milieux enfin
que la la nature n'est pas une gentille
maman hein ou papa hein bon il s'agit
pas de penser moins l'humain mais de le
penser mieux et et donc en fait que
penser nos appartenances euh c'est pas
nous aliéner nécessairement parce que
donc il y a il y a un défi qui est de
celle manière celui de de relire euh euh
notre notre propre héritage à l'égard de
de la pensée des Lumières en particulier
mais mais mais plus largement encore ce
défi c'est de penser ensemble
l'autonomie et euh et l'appartenance
c'est qu'en fait le pour penser notre
autonomie de sujet qui se conquièrent
aussi dans des formes d'émancipation à
l'égard de tout ce qui peut nous aliéner
les pratiques sociales certaines formes
de tradition mais aussi des des
enfermements en fait dans des terroirs
entre guillemets euh euh et bien ben
pour penser l'autonomie est-ce que le
prix à payer c'est celui de
l'arrachement et euh il me semble en
fait que le sans forcément faire une
apologie des racines je me méfie de ce
langage des des racines Steiner dit ça
dit les humains n'ont pas de racine ils
ont des jambes hein donc donc je je me
méfie de ce langage là parce que très
vite on voit comment il peutêre
identitaire enfin pauvrement identitaire
enfin caricature en fait ce que c'est
qu'une identité en définitive euh et
bien donc penser de façon plus profonde
et articuler donc l'autonomie et et
l'appartenance c'est dire effectivement
que nos attachements
euh bien peuvent sont des liens et que
ces liens ne sont pas nécessairement des
liens qui nous aliennent mais que ça
peut être de C façon des liens qui nous
libèrent hein pour oser un peu cette ce
paradoxe enfin nous avons un peu peur de
la dépendance hein nous sommes dans des
cultures où la dépendance est tout de
suite pensée comme une aliénation ou ou
possiblement une aliénation alors qu'en
fait elle est le sens intégré en nous de
nos ouvertures à ce sans quoi on ne
saurait être qui nous sommes donc aut il
s'agit aussi de repenser une conception
ajustée de la dépendance dont la la
catégorie de vulnérabilité de ce point
de vue-là est est est une une expression
hein puisque la vulnérabilité n'est pas
qu'un défaut hein qui annonce des
défaites hein elle est aussi une
capacité d'ouverture euh à se laisser
blesser par ce qui nous fait être hein
d'e certaine façon alors de façon très
littérale vous avez travaillé en soin
palliatif enfin parle de la
vulnérabilité de la dépendance est-ce
que vous pourriez vous en livrer
l'expérience et peut-être le les
conclusions que vous avez pu sur sur la
question en fait des des soins
palliatifs pour moi avant d'être une
spécialité médicale c'est une une pensée
à nouveau frais précisément de la
compréhension que nous avons de la
vulnérabilité alors de fait en fin de
vie on a l'impression que c'est la forme
c'est une des formes en fait de la vie
humaine où l'entrée dans la dépendance
de la très grande dépendance et la porte
ouverte à à la la fin de l'humain alors
qu'en fait c'est le lieu où
s'expérimente le fait que ce qui nous
fait tenir comme vivant parmi les
vivants ce sont des liens donc en fait
dans l'expérience de cette vulnérabilité
la plus grande qui est celle de de
l'alitement définitif avant
effectivement ces derniers jours qui
font la vie et bien il s'agit encore d'y
être vivant hein et donc de lutter Paul
rcker avait cette formule disait
finalement ne confondons pas le
l'agonisant avec le mourant hein donc ne
projetons pas sur la fin de vie le fait
qu'il aurait plus rien à vivre il y a
encore quelque chose à Vidre et qui qui
s'y exauce d' cetteelle manière bah
c'est le fait que c'est tous ces liens
qui nous constituent dans l'être bien
qui s'en trouvent exaucés et tous ces
liens y compris ceux avec les autres
bien sûr nos proches les soignants qui
nous entourent mais aussi les liens avec
les milieux enfin moi j'ai ce qui
m'intéresse en notamment dans les soins
palliatifs c'est de de travailler sur
les milieux de soins et parmi ces
milieux bien l'architecture il y a les
paysages le les les formes du vivant non
humain moi j'ai c'est intéressant de
voir que dans les dans dans les hôpitaux
les animaux sont bannis pas dans les
unités de soin palliatif euh pourquoi
parce que du cette telle manière les
vivants autre qu' humain nous rendent
vivant y compris et viennent nous
chercher encore viennent nous stimuler
ça peut être une minuscule saurelle qui
rentre indument dans la chambre un soir
d'été dans de sa chambre de ce malade ça
peut être la qualité d'un soir et d'une
lumière de d'une lumière d'un soir d'été
ou univers hein ben tous ces élémentsl
en fait ben sont l'expression
effectivement de nos de nos être
vulnérabl c'est-à-dire ouvert à ce qui
vient les susciter et donc en ce sens-là
ça a rien à voir avec la mort hein et
donc quand on a tendance et donc je
crois qu'on est en train de de changer
ça de découvrir que la question des ce
qui se joue en soins palliatif c'est des
questions de la vie c'est pas la
question de de la mort bah ça interroge
qu'est-ce qui nous rend vivant d'ù le
fait que ça peut être surprenant
effectivement que moi je fasse ce pont
entre des questions d'écologie d'un côté
les questions de médecine de l'autre
alors qu'en définitive je crois que le
plus profondément c'est venir interroger
qu'est-ce que signifie pour nous être
vivant ou plus exactement être existant
hein c'est la question que j'allais vous
poser est-ce que c'est la la question du
soin qui vous amener à la question
écologique ou oou est-ce que tout ça
c'est fait de conserve ENF comment
comment ça s'est noué dans votre propre
échobiographie ouais ouais euh
oui c'est c'est toujours un a y a il y a
la fois des des choses insues hein et
qui montent doucement au concept hein
comme on dit hein mais euh j'ai commencé
par travailler effectivement sur les
questions de qu'on appelait qu'on
appelle toujours d'ailleurs les
questions de
bioéthique avec un étonnement hein parce
que dans bioéthique le radical de
bioéthique il ouvre à tout tout ce qui
est vivant hein et les fondateur de la
bioétique Potter en particulier c'est
pas le Harry hein c'est un médecin
américain il il insiste quand il parle
de bioéthique sur l'idée que il y a un
lien autour de la question du vivant
entre le vivant humain le vivant non
humain l'animal et et le vivant végétal
c'est qu'en fait la bioéthique n'est pas
qu'une éthique médicale mais
effectivement ce qu'on en a fait depuis
35 ans c'est
essentiellement une valorisation des
enjeux d'éthique médicale mais d'une
éthique médicale sans milieu si on peut
dire d'une éthique médicale où elle
pensait le vivant indépendamment de et à
un moment ce ce qui m'a frappé c'est il
y a deux choses qui m'ont frappé dans
les questions de bithique la première
c'était découvr IR que notamment dans
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
les techniques qu'on déploie dans
sont des techniques qui sont issues des
biotechnologie animalein technique
d'assémination artificielle pour les ins
les beauvins mise au point par l'INRA
autrement dit les biotechnologie du
vivant elles sont transfrontalières
entre le vivant non humain et le vivant
humain donc ça c'était le premier
élément qui me frappait le second
élément c'était la grande le grand écart
entre disons l'éthique médicale
concernant ce qu'on appelle pauvrement
la la la médecine somatique quoi si on
admettait parce qu'au fond notre
médecine est construite sur un dualisme
même si elle dont elle a du mal à à se
dépétrer d'e certaine façon mais quand
on est en
psychiatrie ce qui est atteint par la
maladie c'est la possibilité de se tenir
là c'est précisément la question du du
design comme on dit dans dans notre
jargon de philosophe he la question de
être là et la maladie elle tient ici
dans le fait que j'arrive pas à y être
hein soit dans le dans l'enfermement
presque sidéré en fait d'un
blottissement qui devient une espèce de
de pétrification de soi soit dans le
langage de la grande errance du du
vagabond euh de l'automate ambulatoire
comme on disait au 19e pour parler des
des grands malades errants en fait qui
cherchaient à se rythmiciser en marchant
et donc les la psychiatrie elle est très
attentive au fait qu'effectivement la la
maladie mentale elle attaque notre
présence au milieu et donc il s'agit de
travailler sur les supports enfin sur
c'estes non pas sur des supports
précisément sur le fait que nos milieux
sont pas simplement des supports sur
lequels nous sommes posés mais sur des
interdépendants qui viennent nous
susciter là aussi qui viennent nous
réveiller donc moi c'est comme ça que je
suis arrivé en fait le je arrivais en
fait à la à la jonction entre la
question de l'écologie et celle de la
médecine en découvrant enfin c'est ce
que dira guatari à sa manière que il y a
il y a pas d'écologie environnementale
s'il y a pas d'écologie sociale et il y
a pas d'écologie sociale s'il y a pas
d'écologie psychique donc il faut
articuler les trois d'où moi ma
perplexité qui est de me dire qu'un
qu'une grande structure comme le conseil
consultatif national d'éthique hein pour
lequel j'ai à la fois beaucoup d'intérêt
et de de respect enfin d'admiration
n'est jamais encore à l'exception
peut-être de la COP euh 21 travailler de
façon centrale sur l'articulation entre
les questions de santé et d'écologie
autrement qu'à partir du modèle du du
facteur enfin de ce qu'on appelle le
facteur environnemental hein ouais mais
la bioéthtique justement vient peut-être
de de ce divorce ou de ce dualisme que
vous avez énoncé entre corps et esprit
ou ou un divorce entre science et et vie
enfin en tout cas l'idée que la science
serit un domaine séparé et qui qui
appelle du coup le l'obligation de de la
traduire alors c'est ce que vous faites
précisément dans dans
l'échobiographie mais c'est vrai que
peut-être enfin comment comment
pourrait-on faire pour arriver à faire
en sorte que la science nous parle
quelle faculté faut-il convoquer est-ce
que c'est l'imagination est-ce que
comment on arrive à ramener la science
sur terre pour qu'elle parle à tout le
monde h av il y a des enjeux qui sont
liés à sa structuration hein euh et puis
donc la conscience que finalement le
type de structuration des savoirs que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui qui est
donc les la division des savoirs en silo
comme on dit des sections de
spécialisation en fait qui fabrique des
grands spécialistes mais en fait qui
alors qu'il nous faudrait penser des
enjeux qui sont transversaux donc en
fait il y a il y a un enjeu à mon avis
majeur qui est de qui est en train de se
faire d'ailleurs qui est de repenser
l'université dans la division de ses
savoirs nous avons construit le modèle
l'université que nous connaissons sur
l'université enfin sur le modèle holtien
d' celle manière et ce modèle il est en
train d'être d'exploser hein parce que
les la partition par exemple sciences de
la nature sciences humaines on voit très
bien qu'elle est plus fait elle est plus
éclairante les problèmes d'écologie en
fait sont les enjeux à la fois de
sciences humaines et des enjeux en fait
de géoscience par exemple donc le il y a
les catastrophes dites naturelles sont
plus naturelles donc enfin pas toutes
mais donc en fait il y a donc il y a la
question de des des de repenser comment
nous articulons les savoirs et puis il y
a il y a un autre enjeu qui est que les
usages sociaux nous faisons de la
science et c'est c'est le sens de votre
question parit que j'entends de les deux
c'est ça vous répondez dans les les
dimensions c'est ça et sur le donc sur
ce second aspect en fait là moi aussi je
suis assez c'est Jean-Pierre dupit qui
faisait cette observation dans un livre
s'appelle catastrophisme éclairé disait
comment se fait-il que nous n'arrivons
pas à croire ce que nous savons ouais
c'est ça voilà et donc en fait ce
divorce ou cette dualité entre ce que
nous savons donc ce que nous nous
prennent nos no nos sciences dans leur
diversité et ce que nous devons faire il
y a un gap donc c'est la question de la
dimension contreintuitive et donc moi
mon travail si ce que je faire c'est il
se love là he c'est que c'est de c'est
d'essayer de comment faire pour qu'une
information dans ce qu'là de de de
conquis de construit de de de très
élaboré mais aussi de très abstraits
parce qu'elle veut se formuler justement
dans le langage de la neutralité
axiologique donc on comment faire donc
que langage rigoureux de la science donc
qui donne des informations bien nous
rejoignent dans la singularité de nos
histoires pour donc dans mon langage je
dis c'est comment faire pour qu'une
information devienne un événement une
information ne fait pas nécessairement
événement on voit très bien une
notification sur un smartphone c'est
c'est une c'est une information c'est
pas encore un événement donc le passage
il passe pour moi par la question du
sensible c'est la question en fait du de
de laisser retentir une information pour
qu'elle puisse avoir la chance de
devenir une histoire et là il y a sans
vouloir les instrumentaliser B c'est là
que les enjeux éthiques sont centux
enfin éthique et politique sont les
opérateurs de traduction hein de celle
manière mais plus particulièrement pour
moi c'est le le rôle que jouent les arts
c'est qu' fait dans la diversité de leur
de leurs
expressions les les arts en fait sont
des enfin sont des
manières de
donner une chair sensible euh enfin il
s'agit pas de les instrumentaliser il
s'agit pas de faire d'eux les comment on
dire les les les commentateurs ou ou les
servants en fait de de l'activité
scientifique mais il y a en fait dans
dans les activités artistiques dans la
pluralité des langages
artistiques une force en fait singulière
parce qu'elle est singularisante hein je
pourrais le dire comme ça en fait le
discours de la science c'est un discours
qui
cherche l'exactitude euh le discours des
arts il cherchent la rectitude et
notamment la la rectitude de l'image
juste et ce qui permet à une information
de devenir pour moi un événement c'est
précisément la médiation de l'image des
images d'où le rôle effectivement de la
fonction éthique de l'imagination
hein si la question d'imagination
m'intéresse c'est parce que
effectivement le l'imagination n'est pas
que la folle du logique on a voulu si
longtemps y voir elle est une elle a un
double double visage enfin une double
dimension elle est à la fois une
capacité bah de venir travailler nos
affects par les images intérieurement
donc en fait de contribuer à NS augment
intérieurement de certaine manière dans
la pluralité des images possibles parce
que les images que travaillent les arts
elles peuvent être joyeuses elles
peuvent être tristes elles peuvent être
glorieuses ou elles peuvent être en fait
aller du côté des choses qui sont un peu
opaques et bon de ce qui fait que nos
vies sont nos vie donc il y a cette
dimension d'intensification
hein donc mais il y a ensuite une
dimension prospective hein c'est que moi
j'aime bien dire que les images qui nous
habitent sont aussi des images qui nous
habilitent hein et et donc ce qui nous
habite intérieurement je évoquéis en
commençant tout à l'heure le il y a en
moi peut-être enfin moi je de Meur
moiselle une qualité de de de de rivière
les Grais les Grais des des vuges en
fait sont des éléments en fait qui m'ont
qui m'ont qui me structurent assez en
fait pour que je puisse dire que je suis
de là de cetteelle façon mais en même
temps ce qui m'habite intérieurement en
fait
m'habilite extérieurement parce que ça
prépare enfin ça ça ça nous sucide dans
nos capacitésin quand je m'autorise le
droit de rêver de certaine façon je me
prépare aussi à à agir hein donc c'est
la question de comment on passe du
poétique à l'éthique et au politique en
fait alors il s'agit jamais pour moi
d'instrumentaliser le poétiique mais de
lui laisser sa chance pour permettre
justement à se capaciter sur C ce
néologisme comme sujet bah capable sur
plan individuel ou collectif le problème
des images c'est qu'elles sont fortement
concurrencées par pléor d'images qui
nous arrivent sur les écrans sur les
réseaux et ce ne sont pas forcément des
des images qui permett de penser il y a
une sorte de saturation qui qui empêche
peut-être même l'imagination comment
comment on fait pour arriver à se
prémunir par l'imaginaire et
l'imagination de l'image justement oui
oui oui ça c'est c'est un des un des
défis du temps
euh c'est le défi de de ce qu'on peut
appeler presque la lassitude
compassionnelle autant en fait de de la
sur diffusion
d'imag donc c'est une une vieille c'est
déjà un vieux problème en fait que
soulevait Walter benjamine en son
tempsin c'est qu'en fait dans quand on
est à l'air de la reproduction infinie
en fait des images bien cellees-ci en
fait passe elles sont précisément elles
ont le statut de d'information et pas
d'événement hein je je lisais là
récemment en fait que sur nos téléphones
portaable on scroll des des kilomètres
d'images par jour et combien nous
affecte dire c'est peut-être une posture
de de philosophe plus vieux en fait qui
et qu' n'y paraît c'est qu'en fait le je
crois en fait qu' a qu'il a un enjeu qui
est d'abord éthique mais je pense qui
est aussi politique hein cet enjeu
éthique c'est de comment précisément
comme individu hein je me laisse la
chance ou pas de me laisser travailler
par les images qui me traversent ça peut
être un choix autrement dit je peux
élire long de la journée dis finalement
quelle image je retiens de cette journée
qui est suffisamment consistante mais ça
veut dire comment on aide les individus
à à à pouvoir avoir cette cette
consistance intérieure de dire c'est
peut-être aussi pour moi un choix de ne
pas simplement me laisser envahir par
une quantité d'images mais de venir les
en élir une qui soit heureuse ou pas
d'ailleurs c'est pas la question ce qui
fait que pour moi le c'est là que
finalement l'enjeu quand même est un
enjeu qui est pas que personnel a
effectivement un discours de sagesse
hein pour ça que je dis que c'est un
discours un peu qui peut paraître un peu
vieillo de dire finalement il y a la
question d'une réforme de soi je c ceci
dit j'en suis persuadé cette dimension
elle est elle est importante mais pour
moi il y a un enjeu qui est politique et
effectivement quel type de société nous
fabriquons lorsque de cette manière nous
encourageons la confusion chez nos
concitoyens entre leurs désirs et leurs
envies pour moi la société de l'image en
fait qui est fortement marquée quand
même par une puissance en fait de
l'industrie l'image c'est-à-dire en fait
d'un marché en fait de l'image il est il
flirte je veux dire sur le
sur la ligne équivoque hein de du désir
d'être profond et de
l'envie telle sorte qu'on fini par ne
sachant plus vraiment faire la frontière
entre une envie et un désir et bien on
finit par croire qu'être abreuvé par
effectivement ce torent d'image c'est ce
qui viendrait nous nous nourrir entre
guillemets intérieurement et là je pense
qu'il y a une responsabilité politique
hein quand on évquer il y a il y a
quelques années cette idée de qu'est-ce
qu'on fait à la télé si ce n'est offrir
du temps disponible en fait pour
Coca-Cola en fait c'est une question
qu'il faut reposer aujourd'hui avec aux
réseaux sociaux en fait on voit très
bien la question que ça pose pour les
plus jeunes d'entre nous parce que
limite quand on est né d'avant avant les
réseaux sociaux on a une expérience en
fait de de ce que c'est que le
retentissement profond et LAN des images
mais pour les plus jeunes quelle chance
on leur laisse à eux de pouvoir aussi
être pas simplement sidérés mais habités
par les images et là la question elle
est politique c'est le rôle du
philosophe aujourd'hui que d'enseigner
ça que
que de prêter attention à que de que
d'accompagner peut-être des étudiants
parce que c'est aussi un métier de
transmission est-ce que est-ce que enfin
comment on pourrait définir le rôle du
philosophe dans notre société
aujourd'hui je pense que le nous les en
fait les les philosophes ont des des moi
je me définis souvent comme une éponge
he c'est ce qui m'intéresse c'est
d'essayer d'être présent à mon présent
et et à l'air et à l'air ou ou à l'eau
du temps et ensuite de trouver les les
bons endroits où ceci puisse se faire où
ce puisse être par partager et et
évoquer avec d'autres et donc pour moi
le rôle du philosophe c'est pas d'être
un idéologue autrement dit j'ai j'ai pas
du tout envie de d'avoir à à à dire aux
autres ce qu'il devrai penser donc je me
méfie beaucoup en fait de du philosophe
idéologue ou qui qui producteur d' une
sorte de prête à penser et donc ça
interroge quels sont les bons endroits
où on doit intervenir donc je je
considère effectivement qu'on a une
responsabilité c'est mes collègues
Brésiliens en fait qui m'avaient alerté
là-dessus parce que moi je me dis
j'étais un universitaire français et
donc le donc la neutralité axiologique
hein on connaît ça en France mais il me
disait toujours mais tu sais que tu le
voilles ou non tu es un leader d'opinion
donc qu'est-ce que nous faisons de notre
responsabilité et donc pour moi c'est de
trouver les lieux où ceci se déploie et
donc on ben je ce qui me désole c'est
que les partis politiques sont plus
beaucoup des espaces où il est possible
de de pouvoir encore élaborer euh des
des une pensée lente et patiente pour
aborder des questions complexes les
églises ne font plus trop non plus d'
certaine façon mais je trouve que c'est
intéressant de voir que dans les milieux
associatifs et les festivals d'idé sont
deux espaces très réjouissants en fait
de ce qui se vit en France aujourd'hui
parce que ce sont des espaces
prépolitiques euh où et bien
effectivement on peut de facir lente
élaborer et bien le monde qui vient dans
la patience du concept mais dans la
rigueur du concept hein merci
Jean-Philippe Pierron merci beaucoup